elle arrête pas de décoder mais fais pas
de grimace il a un coup de vent tu vas
rester bloqué comme ça vous connaissez
on vous l'a déjà fait ce coup là non et
bah c'est possible enfin la paralysie de
belle ça vous parle c'est une paralysie
du visage qui arrive brutalement et qui
touche qu'un seul côté en général avant
on appelait ça la paralysie à frigorée
frigoré ça veut dire froid parce qu'on
pensait que c'était un coup de froid
qu'il a déclenché genre un coup de vent
bon depuis on a découvert qu'en fait ça
serait plutôt à cause d'un virus genre
le virus de l'herpès qui dort pépouse
dans notre corps et tout d'un coup paf
il se réveille oui il fait ça à l'herpès
je sais pas si vous connaissez et si on
en a après du nerf facial à gauche ou à
droite bah il y a une inflammation qui
bloque le nerf et qui provoque une
paralysie à gauche ou à droite c'est
temporaire normalement ça fait pas
plaisir donc non à la base les gens ils
font pas vraiment une grimace c'est la
paralysie faciale qui fait que le visage
est plus symétrique du coup ça peut
faire penser à une grimace et même si on
entend dire que le froid ça pourrait
réactiver le virus il y a rien de
prouver à ce niveau là mais en tout cas
c'est sûrement de là que ça vient cette
histoire de rester bloqué s'il y a un
coup de vent